[Musique]
et quand même très bizarre cette ligne
la 3 bis
sayad gens pour moi c'est la ligne la
plus petite de paris ce mal il ya
combien d'arrêts les quatre vingt quatre
heures et 1 minute compris terminé
seconde beaucoup de métro parisien
en fait tu es dans les mines
déjà existants ok merci pour le tactile
des touristes
[Musique]
jetons
nous voilà dans le xvème pas loin de la
tour eiffel palourdes quête scène on est
pas mal on va les découvrir un nouveau
service de trottinettes je sais y en a
beaucoup à paris de plus en plus qui
s'installe en france que voulez vous ce
que celui d'eric un peu exceptionnel
c'est les 5 de trottinettes du cndd bolt
lors on le connaît plus pour ses
exploits en course grand sportif pour
prendre conseil il faut pas parler
devant la porte de sa loge
[Musique]
bien problème monsieur avec le chanteur
faisait pas loin du vieux monsieur après
forte et très bien
[Musique]
kla vous avez le direct sur tp mp avec
usain bolt est juste là à nous notre
plaque ni nouvelle trotinette du
changement alors une petite course soit
pas juste là on est pas mal
[Musique]
gut enquête du champagne ça va toujours
la danse cnd bonne part les trottinettes
envoi du champagne on est pas mal
envoie du bois faire attention à la
musique point dans notre avec youtube
mais le spot est juste assez incroyable
on a tous fait que je dois rien je sais
pas si vous avez d'avoir assez de
s'avancer vers assure l'avoir quarts de
finale en ce moment ce qu'il y a pas de
monde ici
il s'attaque à séoul on va regarder là
où là
on devine le bout juste leur douala sud
a envoyé ici c'est vraiment brand et
michel bolle donc on va parler des
nouveaux services de trottinettes à
paris je vous dis les trotte pas paris
il y en a trop peut-être que celle-là
pas réussi à l'attention de me trouve à
grands coups de marketing parce que
derrière on line up une figure de proue
comme des chênes bolt le produit net
sont pas noirs nation assez visible
[Musique]
messier alors si ce sont ces mais quel
artiste complet monsieur signaux souvent
fait des choses pour un cadavre à oman
en ciel où hélas tout disparaît mais bon
quand argué j'ai un peu trop cher et mon
casque
ce soir on va pas tomber et venir entre
autres aussi ça m'arrache les cheveux
orange au gabon notamment des pas de
casque ça me va mieux non est ce que
j'ai besoin d'avoir une boîte de capotes
c'est très bizarre et même pour moi se
rassure c'est vraiment hyper bizarre
bon écoute c'est un peu cette idée c'est
déjà ça allait en faire un coup de trop
les gens à mettre des cas sur une
comptine est moi la question à rien face
à la question c'est qui filme tous mes
films et m'a dit toi tu crois tu pas
chaud mais j'ai compris tu crois
[Musique]
non
bref course
elle
j'ai connu bien en peine
[Musique]
mon papa
mais l'expérience expérience
bas les pattes petit trois timbres c'est
un grand classique insultes et
électriciens vous accélérez vous freinez
directement justin avec change
il ya un an qui chante m usain bolt sa
présence bon ça va ça ferait sens et ça
c'est bon le truc un peu bizarre mais
qui a eu pas mal
c'est ce truc là pour mettre les pieds
tu vois je suis pas habitué à ça johnson
tetro le compact et un peu marrant c'est
pour le clapet chez lui ça le clapet
c'est un peu étrange mais bon c'est pas
mal qui tombent pas le design d'un coup
un peu bizarre
ouais c'est étrange mais c'est sympa
mais c'est sûr que ça change du ray tu
vois exactement pour la récupérer sur la
porte en tout cas pourtant n'importe
quoi pour un prix aura plus un casse
faut avoir plus de 18 ans tout va bien
moi je veux la rendre parce que je crois
qu'ils nous servent d'un coup à
l'intérieur tu peut m'enlever la capote
s'en remettait ça n'a pas payé qui
marche i privée d'informations contacter
le spo à la merci tu m'as libérer
libérer des livraisons bon ben voilà
c'est tout pour les trottinettes tard il
est conçu avec le champagne était bon
bon trottinette pas mal moi je me
demande toujours c est ce que cette même
si bolt est ce qu'ils vont trouver leur
place à paris et on parle encore que de
paris parce que peut-être ailleurs dans
d'autres villes mais il ya tellement de
trottinettes ai tellement marre qu'il y
en a combien 4,5 à paris c'est trop
c'est bien mais je bats a été mentionné
du coup il c'est le premier lancement de
la marque se fait à paris je sais pas en
tout cas ils sont là y avait michel
bolle donc tu te dis que tu as vraiment
un lancement qui est énorme il y avait
le gratin en tout cas belle soirée
souhaitons leur coup le service a l'air
intéressant d'ailleurs ce matin j'ai un
petit code l'attendions mais la rue il
est là il est là alors ça c'est mon
numéro de leicester vous allez
strictement rien en faire on a un code
promo vous allez sur l'appli
rentrez le code hays et mme bolt et vous
avez 10 euros dauphin voilà je vous dis
ça je gagne absolument rien c'est pas du
tout vidéos sponsorisées je vous en
parle comme ça sourit fin de la traque à
paris faux ça cool mon avis s'arrête à
peu gasquet tellement non d'entre eux
devaient rentrer là il montre toussaint
frais c'est ce qu'il ya de bien avec la
concurrence et que c'est toujours
bénéfique pour le consommateur donc
normalement le client final devrait être
le grand gagnant chez accor tarifs qui
se baissent après le problème c'est que
dans paris tu as tellement trop de
partout que souvent elles sont posées
n'importe comment
et des fois c'est compliqué livre assez
compliqué à voir mais écoute ça ouvre de
plus en plus de d'offres donc peut-être
moins de galères pour légende entre une
chrono c'est moins technique du sud
c'est moizer tu dis en chocolat au
chocolat t-il gecko latine mais a tout
faux mexes et pains au chocolat à la
voix le débat en commentaire il faut
parler de la traite également
bon je vous embrasse on s'arrache parce
que là il est tard on va s'coucher bonne
nuit on appelle chose à faire voilà mes
yeux mais qu be do sul camin pouces
briser la glace
allez bisous
m